individual liberties drugs the prison
system which is loaded with nonviolent
drug offenders that should have gotten
no harsher sentence than a high five
yeah I'm that guy Doug Stanhope is a
beloved comedian known for his caustic
dark honest humor if there were no
afterlife how could my mother have
bought me and my friends so many nice
things from the SkyMall catalog on her
credit card
four days after she passed
from this road his new book digging up
mothers a tribute to his late mom Bonnie
Annan true Stan Hope style it's a
bizarre and charming mixture of scummy
debauchery relentless self-criticism
biting social commentary and of course
straight-up common Stanhope sat down
with us to discuss comedy what
Alcoholics Anonymous taught him about
stand-up his time dabbling in
libertarian presidential politics and
how his mother for better or worse
shaped him into the man he is today let
me start by saying that Reason magazine
is the only magazine that I subscribe to
and actually pay the bill Wow other ones
like The Economist bill me later and I'd
never pay it reason I actually pay the
bill well thank you for keeping up with
that payment and when I'm done I always
leave them in the pocket in the airplane
so other people get the message your
memoir is this insane tale of debauchery
drugs comedy and love and the central
character is your mother Bonnie issue as
a an alcoholic suffered from depression
was a truck driver a bartender and then
an actress a failed comedian for a
minute which I had to watch and it was
really painful he'll head you have
vicodin addict and suicidal funny she
was a caretaker who abused her patients
she was evil yet vollhardt you seem to
both have a love of comedy yeah whereas
your dad is portrayed as this like
really nice and pleasant guy who doesn't
really get the joke but even the armor
like on this weird level could you talk
about you know comedy with it early on
she was she was dragging us to Richard
Pryor when he had his movie in theaters
his live stand-up movie and we're 10
years old and she's dragging us to stuff
like that and leaving hustler magazine
around so and I'd read all the truly
tasteless jokes the cartoons and yeah I
developed a very adult sense of humor
way too early to be bringing it to the
schoolyard
there's an example in your book of one
of your homework assignments it was one
of those things where you like have to
write a sentence with the vocabulary
word right I was wondering if you might
read a couple of those for us and
absolutely about what aides were you
hear this I would have been around 11:00
okay this type of humor is what got me
sent to psychologists he is the most
skillful hit man in Chicago they all
said he was the worst aim until they saw
his flaming arrow ripped between the
man's eyes third sentence it was the
most pleasant of the protesters who were
slain by National Guard machine-gun fire
and finally it was easier to crunch the
baby's head in the Vice so yeah you turn
in homework like that when you're 11
they're not thinking class clown right
they're thinking a troubled kid right
current-day they think school shooter
and the teachers sent you to for
psychological counseling and yeah this
was like a whole theory at array of
tests and Rorschach exams and I had to
draw a picture of my family so I had my
stepfather banging my mother doggy style
my brother was killing a cat with a
knife and I was hanging myself because I
thought that is funny I just had a dark
sense of humor which just speeded up the
cycle he needs to go to counseling
there's something wrong with this kid
yeah at a dark sense of humor but it was
just jokes and so they were freaking out
how did your mother react my mother that
was the kind of [ __ ] we'd talk about
around the dinner table that she just
kind of ignored it and would defend me
when she had to we would go to the
school psychologist the counselor and
we'd you know do the same thing we did
to her in grocery stores where we go mom
are we gonna have to have our beatings
today and the guy just almost drop his
clipboard go what's this about beatings
and she'd have to explain this is just
our sense of humor and I mean this is
like the kind of early forming of a
comedians mind but the school is
medicalizing it as something that needs
to be treated and something wrong with
you how many
brilliant minds that are thinking
outside the box I hate the expression
but just have different personalities
are being crushed by the school system
that says no you just follow the rules
and don't step out of line Benjamin
Franklin what's going to put under a
72-hour watch as a danger to himself and
others flying a kite in a rainstorm is
what's a kid's suicidal he's got a key
on a kite in a lightning storm there's
this trend now in higher education a lot
of comedians have been talking about
they won't perform on college campuses
because the kids are also oh they also
sit there with a blank index card
waiting for you to say the wrong thing
so they can make a protest on your
perform on college note a half a dozen
colleges back years ago made the mistake
of booking me after a NACA convention
and I'm sure every single one of those
student activity directors was fired for
having me on the stage word got out no
more it's now hook on campus no never
again nor would I want to you don't want
to perform in that environment the book
opens with the death of your mother
which was a kind of assisted suicide
cocktail party could you pseudo assisted
for legal reasons yeah I'll be making
the cocktails I don't know how many
morphine pills you're taking I turn a
blind eye but yeah we made it into a
cocktail party slash roast because she
did have a dark sense of humor right up
until the end and and it was it was a
fantastic way to go I wish Comedy
Central would pick that up for for their
roasts do doing it to someone on their
deathbed because that's the way I'd want
to go it's such a contentious issue now
like a lot of states are changing this
issue it was just changed here in
California it's now loud yeah it's sad
that you have to go to some places
depressing is Oregon to kill yourself
you should be able to do it in a sunnier
place but I think the tide is turning we
had a like just talking in yo mumbo
jumbo well if someone were to kill
themselves how much of this dosage would
they need and they not I'm going to kill
my
because she knows I can't know even
though I know right it seems like the
hospice workers are kind of like given a
little like wink wink and this is how
you theoretically do this so yeah oh you
want to do you want three weeks worth
now all right gotcha
in case you want to make your own choice
but there's people who don't have a
choice because people with locked-in
syndrome
I was Stephen Hawking gonna kill himself
if he wanted to
you can't blink yourself to death on a
screen so your mom had a lot of problems
with alcohol and she would take you
along with her to AAA meetings yes yeah
she sobered up when I was around seven
years old so I basically grew up in a a
how did that experience going to a
meetings as a child a shape work video
to work if you've never been to an a a
meeting it's almost like they're
advertising alcohol when they speak
because they make all these stories
grandiose they build them up and they're
laughing during them and and then I had
stabbed and then I woke up in there you
know another town and I didn't have my
pants on and everyone's laughing and
they sum it up with some moral and thank
God for the program I don't have fun
like that anymore so you're listening to
this and it's very adult in content they
don't censor their language and you're
twelve years old in the back of the room
I'm laughing my balls off and I'm sure a
lot of just the storytelling in AAA I'm
sure was had to be of some influence to
me making light of the most dire
situations in life and that's what I
gravitate towards in my act as a
treatment organization you've actually
been kind of critical of a I think it's
five of the 12 steps or about you
turning your life over to God and it
doesn't matter you know what God it is
you they say oh yeah door knob can be
your God as long as you're turning your
life and your will over to I first of
all I'm a drunk this is probably not the
best time for me to be creating my own
omnipotent deity they should have a more
structured guide it's just silly
if you went to an oncologist
and said hey what's this lump and I told
you to just pray and have faith you go
ocean I'm screwed everyone in the book
is fairly nomadic and you kind of just
go places because you think it would be
funny to live in Idaho Orson yes I've
always been very impulsive I've planned
very little so and and now the place
you've landed in is Bisbee Arizona that
is a kind of small border town in
Arizona
why Bisbee why are you there it's just a
town I fell in love with when I lived in
LA and I Drive out to go on the road had
a couple of days to kill between gigs
and Phoenix and El Paso so I just took
back roads and you go through this
tunnel and you're like what the hell is
this town it's an old mining town but
it's artists took it over in the 70s
when the mine shut and it's gorgeous
it's perfect I hate traffic I don't like
people much and it's right out on the
Mexican border so I'm right by the fire
exit when Trump gets elected get out
before they build that wall you've had
some involvement in the mayoral race
there in Bisbee could you tell me a
little bit about that you have two
friends they're like 40 year old beavis
and butthead friends that just sit
around my house all the time and get
high and watch the price is right and we
thought it would be funny to run run
them both run run them against each
other and ignore all the legitimate
candidates I don't know if they'll get
enough signatures to actually get on the
ballot but in the meantime we're making
the town's folks sweat these guys are
actually running you actually sort of
ran for president at one point under
yeah literally were funny no 8 and I
think I lasted about a month and once it
got into the paperwork and off you're
doing this legit you know I can't
mention this on stage without the money
I make from the gig being considered
campaign contributions in like I there's
way too many rules and I screw up way
too many times in a day to be facing
six-figure fines for not dotting and I
crossing a tee even following any of the
libertarian oh I follow Gary Johnson I'm
a huge supporter of Gary and want to get
them on my podcast but I live too far
away that guys fantastic
hopefully the Trump you know rats
fleeing the Republican Party will
actually give the the LP a boost what do
you like about Gary Johnson's message I
don't know [ __ ] about the economic side
of the Libertarian Party one of the
reasons I bowed out I'm never going to
learn this but just in individual
liberties drugs the prison system which
is loaded with nonviolent drug offenders
that should have got no harsher sentence
than a high five for selling drugs you
mentioned Trump too what is Hillary not
a viable alternate I dread at this age
being almost 50 and having no kids and
no care about the future and no hot
prospects for living a long life Trump
I'd take over Hillary just for the
entertainment value they're just
entertainment to me it's no different
than professional sports no president my
entire lifetime has affected me
personally on any direct level that I
could point to so yeah it's a guy you
have to watch out or lady you have to
watch on CNN and she's a terrible
actress
walking round my chair
moving to try job buddy